- Oh, man. I really got
away with one this time.
So I was trying to figure
out how to celebrate
two million subscribers on
this channel, and they say
that when the student is
ready, the master appears,
and the timing couldn't have
been better, because I saw
an article that said Rudy
Giuliani had joined Cameo.
Cameo, If you don't know, is
a service where celebrities
of various kinds offer to
record short cell phone videos
for various reasons and you
send 'em to your friends.
Congratulations, or just
asking them a quick question.
And Rudy Giuliani was a member of Cameo.
For the low, low price of $200,
you could get him to
say just about anything.
It's only gone up since then.
So I filled out the form,
I mentioned my name,
that I was celebrating
two million subscribers.
I didn't say the channel name,
but I was really worried because
if he had found my channel,
he would have seen that
based on the videos
that our interests are
not exactly aligned,
in that our judicial philosophies are,
shall we say, different.
And I'm sorry to report that
this is exactly what happened.
This video is clickbait.
Rudy Giuliani was onto the ruse.
He respectfully declined
to make a video for me,
and we went our separate ways.
(upbeat music)
I'm of course kidding.
Rudy Giuliani did no research whatsoever.
He happily recorded a video the same day
that I sent in a request,
and I am thrilled to
present to you the video
of Rudy Giuliani congratulating me
on two million subscribers.
- Hi, Devin. I'm calling
to congratulate you-
- So, Rudy, this isn't really a call.
You're not calling,
this isn't a voice chat,
this isn't FaceTime.
You're recording this
video and sending it to me.
This isn't a two way street,
but I guess we'll talk
more about that soon.
But thank you for that congratulations.
- On quite an accomplishment-
- Thank you.
- Having you reach two million subscribers
on your YouTube channel.
- Thank you very much.
I am so thrilled to have
reached two million subscribers.
I couldn't have done it
without all of the people
that watch Legal Eagle day in and day out,
and it's an honor to
run the world's largest
law-related YouTube channel,
one you clearly didn't look up
before you gave me this heartfelt thanks.
- That is a, that is a,
really, really quite a thing,
and something you should be very proud of.
- Thank you very much.
I am, I'm so proud of it.
Thank you. Thank you for those kind words.
- You're an ace attorney
and a Legal Eagle.
- That's so nice of you to
use the name of the channel
that you didn't look up.
I do think that I am an ace attorney,
and quite a Legal Eagle.
It means nothing coming
from you in particular
because of the fact that, you know,
you're not actually licensed
to practice anymore because
of all the nefarious
things you tried to do
to undermine our democracy.
But I do like to think
of myself as someone
that's not so much
following in your footsteps,
so much as avoiding your
footsteps altogether.
- And I admire really good attorneys.
- Who are the attorneys that
Rudy Giuliani looks up to?
I would very much like to know
the answer to that question.
I assume that included in
that group is Sidney Powell,
and frankly, all of us should find someone
that looks at them the
way that Rudy Giuliani
looks at Sidney Powell.
And speaking of Sidney
Powell and the whole team
of kraken wranglers, I
should note that Rudy sent me
this video on the exact same day
that I put in my request to Cameo.
And I think that probably makes
sense, because notoriously,
Trump hasn't paid him for any of the legal
or quasi-legal services
that Rudy provided.
and I think he probably
needs the money to fight off
all the lawsuits that
Dominion and Smartmatic
had filed against him and
the entire Sidney Powell
election fraudster team.
So I think at this point,
it's probably safe to say
that I have made more money from Trump
than Rudy Giuliani has.
I'll let that one sink in for a second.
- I would really appreciate
it if you would communicate
with me a contact so that
I can listen to your show,
and I'd love to talk to you at some point.
- Yeah, so that's gonna be...
that's gonna be really hard,
because this is a one-way medium.
It's, again, not a call of any kind.
I have no way of
contacting you whatsoever.
Additionally, on YouTube,
you don't listen to the shows
so much as you watch them on
YouTube, because it's video.
You watch them in addition
to listening to them.
So I don't think that I'm going
to be reaching out to you,
except through this particular video,
but I appreciate the sentiment, thank you.
- It sounds like they're
very, very impressed with you,
and I certainly am impressed
with the large number
of subscribers you were able to achieve.
- Thank you very much.
- So good luck.
I hope you double it.
Whatever, the sky's the limit, go for it.
It sounds like you're that kind of person.
- I think I am.
And probably through the
help of this particular video
that you unwittingly made a cameo in,
I hope to increase the
number of subscribers
that watch Legal Eagle, the
world's largest law-related
YouTube channel that you did
not do any research about
before you issued this Cameo
wishing me congratulations.
So thank you for that.
- And God bless you.
- You know, I'd feel bad.
He seems like such a nice guy.
I'd feel bad if it weren't
for all of the attempts
to destroy America's democracy.
I'm sure Eichmann was a real nice guy
in conversation as well,
except for, you know,
all the unpleasantness in the 40s.
I almost feel bad about
tricking Rudy Giuliani into
wishing me a congratulations
on two million subscribers.
- God bless you.
Thanks. Now, as funny
as this whole thing is,
I'd be remiss if I didn't
turn it into a learning
opportunity, because I think
there's a lot of things
that we can all learn
from Rudy's debasement
in this whole affair.
The first is that your
reputation is everything.
Once that's gone, it's never coming back.
The other is that you
should choose your clients
very carefully, because
if they don't pay you
and are notorious for
skipping out on the bill,
then you might need money
by doing crazy things
like going on Cameo for the
cash, especially when you're not
able to actually practice as a lawyer.
Because one of the main
differences between Rudy and myself
is I'm actually still licensed to practice
in the state of New York.
And perhaps the most
important lesson of all
is that if a YouTuber asks you
to provide some video footage
to them and pays you $200
to say some nice things
about them, perhaps you should
do a modicum of research
to actually, you know, find
out who that YouTuber is.
So kids, don't be like Rudy Giuliani,
or I'll see you in court.